[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 dans
l'actualité de ce lundi 25 septembre à
quasiment 300 jours des Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 la colline d'Élancourt
accueillait hier son événement test de
VTT 3000 spectateurs sont venus admirer
les meilleurs athlètes du monde une
compétition qui a vu la victoire de deux
Français louana le comté Victor koretski
rendez-vous réussi selon Tony estanguay
président du comité d'organisation des
JO qui était sur place près de la moitié
des sièges du Sénat ont été renouvelés
hier à l'occasion du scrutin des
sénatoriales comme au niveau national la
droite reste majoritaire dans les
Yvelines avec quatre sièges obtenus le
mouvement présidentiel Renaissance
conserve son siège avec Martin lévrier
et plus inattendu la gauchyblinoise fait
son retour au Palais du Luxembourg avec
l'élection de Ghislaine Séné un million
de malades sont soignés grâce au don du
sang mais des stocks sont loin d'être
suffisants manque d'in formations peur
du don les raisons peuvent être
multiples pour ceux qui hésitent ce
geste primordial ne prend pourtant
qu'une heure TV 78 s'est rendu à la
maison du don au Chesnay Rocancourt et
puis l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième partie
d'édition retour sur l'événement
métamorphose urbaine il y a quelques
jours le département des Yvelines
organisés à Chanteloup-les-Vignes ce
premier colloque dédié à la
transformation des quartiers
prioritaires explications avec Catherine
Arnoux vice-présidente du conseil
départemental
un avant-goût des Jeux Olympiques à
Élancourt un test Steven grandeur nature
était organisé ce dimanche 24 septembre
sur la colline qui va accueillir les
épreuves de VTT à l'occasion des JO de
Paris 2024 objectif de ce rendez-vous
tester le tracé avec les athlètes la
restauration sur place l'accueil des
équipes et des journalistes et enfin
tester la circulation des spectateurs
sur et en dehors du site une mine
d'information très très importante pour
nous qui seront débriefés là dans les
prochains jours mais globalement les
indicateurs sont au vert le site il est
il est très chouette il plaît aux
athlètes il va y avoir de très très
belles compétitions l'année prochaine on
repart avec beaucoup d'énergie on sait
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de travail
dans les 10 mois qui viennent mais
globalement on repart quand même avec
plus de sérénité à l'issue de ce test au
total près de 5000 personnes étaient
présentes sur place dont 3000
spectateurs dans la foule un vététiste
local qui est monté plusieurs fois au
sommet de cette colline ça fait plaisir
parce que depuis maintenant 25 ans
quasiment on organise la Revan ici donc
on sait nous qui avons créé les premiers
chemins donc ça fait forcément plaisir
de voir les chemins qu'on a pris et ton
tout petit qu'on a créé être utilisé par
les Jeux Olympiques je la reconnais même
s'il y a eu pas mal de travail défectuer
dessus pas mal de structures qui ont été
montées ce qui rend vraiment le circuit
plus difficile que les courses qu'on
organise une belle journée sur le plan
sportif également pour les français chez
les dames Loana le conte terme première
de cette compétition amicale et Pauline
Ferrand Prévot monte sur la troisième
marche du podium chez les hommes Victor
koretski termine également premier mais
le principal était avant tout de tester
cette nouvelle piste olympique c'est un
parcours très
des gros trucs techniques qui qui font
vraiment se poser des questions mais le
tout fait que ça reste hyper exigeant du
vrai VTT moderne en fait et
c'est top et moi j'adore ces changements
de rythme et voilà ça me correspond
plutôt bien les supporters français
rêvent déjà de voir ces Français briller
de nouveau dans 10 mois sur cette
colline dès l'encours les épreuves de
VTT pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris
2024 seront organisés les 28 et 29
juillet d'ici là les organisateurs vont
améliorer des éléments de cette piste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien écoutez une journée magnifique
d'abord une météorologie très favorable
c'était pas le cas au milieu de semaine
encore vendredi ici tomber des cordes
donc on a pu voir la qualité du terrain
qui en moins de 24 heures à
intégralement sécher d'un point de vue
accès c'était un point très important
pour nous vérifiez que l'accès
Jean-Pierre Timbaud pour le public
fonctionnait bien et que l'accès rue à
la colère était également utilisé pour
les accréditer et toute la partie
technique bien écoutez le fonctionnement
est à 100% optimal la partie transport
est très réussie on aura des points de
réglage c'est aussi le but de ce genre
de test
[Musique]
donc on a vu qu'on avait un petit point
de faiblesse sur l'arrivée en gare de
Saint-Quentin et la reprise des navettes
c'est un point qu'on avait déjà signalé
d'ailleurs en phase préparatoire auprès
d'Île de France mobilité on a encore
quelques endroits peut-être ou les
passages pour les spectateurs sont un
peu étroits je pense sur un nécessité
tout en respectant les règles
écologiques qui sont très strictes de
les allergir un petit peu on est fin
prêt à entreprendre la dernière phase de
travaux celle qui nous amènera jusqu'aux
Jeux Olympiques dans maintenant un petit
peu plus de 10 mois
[Musique]
l'héritage on le voit déjà c'est déjà le
fait d'avoir une piste de VTT d'avoir
expulsé de ce lieu le maximum de plantes
invasives il y a eu un très gros travail
écologique qui a été qui a été fait
ensuite nous aurons la création pendant
un an des pistes complémentaires ces
pistes qui vous permettront à vous et à
moi et à l'ensemble des 5 continents et
de ceux qui viendront de toute la France
de pratiquer un VTT pas seulement de
haut niveau mais du débutant jusqu'au
plus haut niveau avec je le rappelle 5
couleurs de piste différentes un peu
comme au ski un des bleus des jaunes des
verbes des rouges des Noirs le meilleur
héritage ça sera de le rendre aux
familles pour qu'elles puissent se
promener et en même temps voir des
sportifs de haut niveau de points au
niveau qui utiliseront ces pistes
[Applaudissements]
la droite conserve sa majorité au Sénat
c'est également le cas dans le
département la liste une équipe pour
toutes les Yvelines menées par Gérard
Larcher arrivent en tête des
sénatoriales avec plus de 57% des voix
elle perce pendant un siège par rapport
à la précédente mandature ce
renouvellement sénatorial conforte la
majorité sénatoriale de la droite et du
centre est témoigne de son ancrage
territorial dans un contexte politique
marqué par l'absence de majorité au sein
de l'Assemblée nationale plus que jamais
le Sénat incarne ce pôle de stabilité ce
point d'équilibre de la République face
à la crise profonde que traverse notre
pays en deuxième position ensemble agir
pour les Yvelines la liste de la
majorité présidentielle conduite par
Martin lévrier conserve son siège avec
près de 15% des voix
accompli et
une équipe qui a su gagner presque 90
voix en 6 ans donc ce qui est un une
preuve d'une véritable implantation même
auprès des élus du département et ça
c'était très très important de montrer
que le terrain nous étions sur le
terrain et que nous avions valorisé le
terrain mais la grande surprise de ces
sénatoriales vient de la gauche une
nouvelle voie pour les Yvelines totalise
un peu plus de 13% des suffrages la tête
de liste Ghislaine Séné obtient donc un
siège la gauche yvelinoise fait son
retour au Palais du Luxembourg après 6
ans d'absence
et bien quand
les parties de goût de bouche se font
l'Union dans les Yvelines et ben en fait
grâce à cela on a pu retrouver le poste
que nous avions perdu en 2017 je crois
que la voix de de l'écologie
et de la solidarité doit se faire plus
entendre au Sénat dans les Yvelines 8
listes étaient candidates notamment le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise qui arriver ait en quatrième
et cinquième position elle ne décroche
pas de siège quant au sénateur élu ils
entreront en fonction le 2 octobre
prochain première séance dédiée à
l'élection du président de la Chambre
haute
le procès de l'attentat de Magnanville a
débuté ce lundi devant la cour d'assis
spécial de Paris un homme de 30 ans
comparé seul pour complicité
d'assassinats terroristes kidnapping et
associations de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminels cet individu proche du
terroriste est accusé d'avoir été
présent sur les lieux du crime au moment
des fêtes le 13 juin 2016 un couple de
policiers Jean-Baptiste Salvin et
Jessica Schneider ont été assassinés au
couteau à leur domicile de Magnanville
le terroriste avait été abattu par le
Raid le verdict du procès est attendu
pour le 10 octobre l'accusé encourt la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité le
rectorat de Versailles de nouveau dans
la tourmente après la révélation
d'autres courriers menaçants adressé à
des familles c'est notamment le cas d'un
père qui avait dénoncé des faits
d'attouchement sexuel sur sa fille en
mars dernier l'Académie était déjà dans
le viseur depuis la publication de la
lettre adressée aux parents de Nicolas
l'adolescent victime de harcèlement
scolaire qui s'est suicidé début
septembre à Poissy ce week-end Charline
Avenel l'ancienne rectrice qui était au
poste au moment en effet à présenter ses
excuses à la famille dans les colonnes
du Parisien en pleine polémique Gabriel
Attal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est rendu au rectorat cet
après-midi
la première école de commerce de
Mantes-la-Jolie ouvre en octobre baptisé
manschool of business l'établissement
pour accueillir 180 étudiants les
inscriptions pour la rentrée 2023 sont
encore possibles vous pouvez vous
inscrire jusqu'à début novembre sur le
site de l'établissement 4 BTS et de
Bachelor sont proposés
peut-être que comme moi vous avez
longtemps hésité à donner votre sang
pour moi c'était la peur des aiguilles
pourtant j'ai sauté le pas il y a deux
ans avec Julien Leroy derrière la caméra
on va vous montrer comment ça se passe
s'il y a de nombreuses collectes mobiles
des dons peuvent être fait à la maison
du don du chenérocancourt je suis
accueillie par un membre de l'équipe de
collecte qui vérifie mon identité et me
donne un questionnaire à remplir avec
une bouteille d'eau à boire entièrement
mon questionnaire est rempli je patiente
avant de rencontrer un médecin
l'occasion de faire le point avec
Stéphane Noël le directeur de l'efsi de
France Stéphane bonjour Alors on dit que
historiquement les stocks sont bas c'est
toujours le cas en 2023 leur
historiquement on espère qu'il le soit
jamais trop bas et notre travail c'est
en permanence d'anticiper les choses
pour faire en sorte que tous les jours
les patients de la région et les
produits sanguins dont ils ont besoin
pour être pris en charge donc oui nous
rencontrons régulièrement des périodes
de fortes tensions sur les stocks et
tout ça on l'a rencontré beaucoup
pendant la crise covid on l'a rencontré
en d'autres circonstances pendant les
ponts durant le printemps et puis
actuellement c'est la rentrée la rentrée
classiquement une période pendant
laquelle les stocks sont tendus voire
très ce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête
c'est que les produits sanguins ont une
durée de vie qui est très limitée 42
jours pour les concentrés de globules
rouges 7 jours pour les plaquettes et de
fait tous les jours il faut absolument
reconstituer les stocks des produits qui
ont été consommés la veille bonjour
c'est le moment du rendez-vous avec le
médecin pour s'assurer que je peux
donner j'ai bien entre 18 et 70 ans et
je pèse au moins 50 kg mais secret
médical oblige cette séquence ne sera
pas enregistrée si l'on connaît le
fameux O négatif les groupes sanguins de
personnes originaires des continents
africains indiens ou des Caraïbes sont
très recherchés on les appelle les 100
rares
c'est enfin le moment de donner claire
marron infirmière va s'occuper de moi on
y va chère Madame on y va c'est le
passage le plus compliqué pour moi mais
pas de douleur particulière pas plus
qu'une simple prise de sang en moyenne
c'est entre 8 et 10 minutes d'accord
c'est pas un concours parce qu'on
prélève quand même 480 ml donc il faut
que votre organisme ce soit relax
d'accord les 10 minutes sont écoulées on
peut passer au moment convivial 20
minutes sont à respecter pour s'assurer
que vous pouvez repartir boisson
collation et échanges avec l'équipe et
voilà le don est terminé ça nous a pris
une heure très exactement à la fin on
m'a remis un document avec des consignes
à respecter pendant les prochaines
heures et les prochains jours prochain
dont pour moi peut-être dans un peu plus
de 8 semaines le but ne pas dépasser les
quatre sur 12 mois complets
[Musique]
on commence par du golf l'Open de France
à livrer son verdict ce dimanche après 4
jours de compétition sur le Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est le
japonais Rio issatsun qui remporte la
victoire le golfeur asiatique de 21 ans
gagne la compétition avec un score total
de -14 il devance de deux coups le
Danois Jeff Winter et l'anglais Jordan
Smith le premier Français Julien brun
termine en sixième position de ce 105e
Open de France on écoute le japonais
je ne pensais pas pouvoir gagner
je suis très content
c'est ma première victoire je suis si
heureux un peu plus tôt ce dimanche la
44e course Paris Versailles était
organisée à partir de 10 heures sur
l'avenue de Paris ria de GERFI accroche
un premier Paris Versailles à son
palmarès avec un chrono de 50 minutes et
45 secondes il devance le bolivien
Hector garibet chez les femmes samantha
fektos est imposé en 59 minutes et 5
secondes avec 3 minutes d'avance sur
l'américaine Catherine Golding le
rendez-vous a réuni plus de 25000
coureurs cette année sont partis de la
Tour Eiffel pour arriver à Versailles en
passant par la côte des gardes Kevin et
Guillaume Torin de coureurs originaire
des Yvelines ont filmé ces images de
leurs courses on regarde
[Musique]
en football FC Versailles chute à
domicile dans le championnat de National
les Versailles se sont inclinés ce
vendredi sur leur pelouse face à
Villefranche Beaujolais sur le score de
1 but à zéro à l'occasion de la septième
journée après ce résultat les jours de
la cité royale pointe à la 15e place du
championnat à 3 points du dernier Épinal
prochain match ce vendredi 29 septembre
sur la pelouse de Nancy toujours en
football et dirigeant du PSG ne seraient
pas tout à fait satisfait de leur
nouveau son d'entraînement à Poissy la
raison il y aurait trop de vent sur le
Training Center certains salariés qui
travaillent confient qu'il est difficile
d'avancer lorsqu'il arrive de face à
certains endroits du lieu le bruit de
l'autoroute A13 serait aussi un élément
perturbateur pour le staff les joueurs
et les employés le nouveau centre
d'entraînement devait être inauguré à
l'automne mais la date a été retardée
enfin on termine par du rugby on jouait
ce week-end la deuxième journée de
Fédérale 2 plaisir s'impose sur le
terrain de Versailles sur le score le 38
à 21 de son côté Maisons-Laffitte
s'incline sur la pelouse d'Auxerre 25 à
19 au classement plaisir et premier avec
10 points vers ailles et 9e et le MLSGP
dixième
un ciel voilé au menu de votre journée
de mardi dans les Yvelines il fera 14
degrés à Versailles Mantes-la-Jolie et
Rambouillet 13 degrés à Houdan même
condition l'après-midi côté température
s'agrimpe avec 23 degrés prévus sur
l'ensemble du département et demain
mardi 26 septembre nous fêterons les
cônes tout de suite l'invité du 7 8
[Musique]
un premier coloc dédié à la
transformation des quartiers
prioritaires le département des Yvelines
l'a organisé ce jeudi 21 septembre sous
le Phénix de Chanteloup-les-Vignes et
pour en parler et Catherine Arnoux
bonjour bonjour vous êtes mère justement
de la commune de Chanteloup-les-Vignes
mais aussi vice-présidente du conseil
départemental en charge de l'insertion
et de la rénovation urbaine sur les
quartiers politiques de la ville dans
les Yvelines il y en a 31 un quartier
prioritaire ce qui représente une
population de 157.000 habitants sujets
d'importance pourquoi tout simplement
lancer ce premier colloque pour
co-organiser cet événement ce jeudi 21
septembre à Chanteloup-les-Vignes
d'abord pour partager pour partager la
volonté politique du département depuis
2015 le département c'est lourdement
engagé je crois que c'est le seul
département de France qui a mis cette
volonté politique à accompagner les
quartiers prioritaires dans leur
transformation pas seulement ceux qui
avaient été retenus par l'État au titre
de l'agence de rénovation urbaine mais
aussi tous les quartiers qui étaient
déjà en politique de la ville et qui
avait montré déjà des fragilités
urbaines
nous avons accompagné donc dans un
premier mandat nous avons accompagné
13 quartiers prioritaires et puis nous
continuons notre volonté politique dans
ce deuxième mandat en étant attentif à
ces quartiers qui 60 prioritaires soit
en décrochage soit en risque de
décrochage parce que l'intelligence de
la politique c'est d'arriver avant c'est
de voir ce qui a été le drame de nos
quartiers prioritaires depuis 40 ans et
de savoir donner aux collectivités aux
élus aux habitants les moyens de
transformer durablement leur quartier ce
programme c'est prioriveline et on parle
pas que de rénovation urbaine c'est un
programme un peu plus global pour pour
ces quartiers prioritaires alors le
département c'est a pris lourdement la
compétence politique de la ville ça
regroupe évidemment l'urbain parce que
là on va être beaucoup dans l'urbain
mais l'urbain qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
pour accompagner les habitants à mieux
vivre avoir non seulement une qualité de
vie mais une qualité de service que
peuvent lui proposer les collectivités
locales mais qui ont besoin pour ça de
l'appui du département alors oui c'est
l'occasion aussi de penser la ville de
demain cette ville qui a été construite
dans des qui ont été construites
toujours dans des dans des conditions
extrêmement rapides qui évidemment ne
pensait pas du tout développement
durable il y a 40 ans ça n'était pas le
thème et qui pensait assez mal
l'insertion et l'inclusion donc on a
voulu et c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui
est ce qui est aujourd'hui la les
échanges c'est en fait d'échanger
d'abord sur ce que fait le département
les projets mais aussi d'échanger nos
compétences d'échanger nos regards
éventuellement de dézoomer nos regards
avec des intervenants extérieurs qui
nous qui nous expliquent qui qui nous
font dézoomer repenser et puis c'est
aussi mettre l'accent sur cette petite
particularité des départements des
Yvelines qui dans son accompagnement à
la politique de la ville au
renouvellement urbain c'est donner une
vocation forte c'est la relation la
vocation éducative et l'essentiel des
projets de renouvellement urbain des
Yvelines ce sont des projets qui sont
tournés autour de l'éducation
essentiellement autour de l'enfant aussi
aussi autour de la petite enfance et
puis aussi autour de cette ville
inclusive qui doit effectivement inclure
tous les habitants des quartiers on va
revenir sur le programme de ces tableaux
de vous avez parlé d'acteurs justement
pour vous accompagner durant cette
journée qui sont-ils on imagine des
experts sur la question de la rénovation
sur la question de des quartiers
prioritaires leur des experts de notre
territoire parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
des experts d'autres territoires qui ont
déjà un passé et une lecture de la
rénovation urbaine et puis des experts
qui regardent qui regardent l'évolution
de la société dans sa globalité et on a
pu justement interroger quelques-uns de
ces experts qui étaient présents pour
cette journée du jeudi 21 septembre
j'interviens sur la thématique de
l'urbanisme temporaire transitoire et
dans les cadres des projets de
renouvellement urbain la rue considère
que c'est une opportunité pour améliorer
la transformation du cadre de vie des
habitants donc pour moi c'est très
intéressant c'est de valoriser ce sujet
là et de partager les acquis les
différents acteurs du renouvellement
urbain avec la communauté
professionnelle qui va être réunie
aujourd'hui on travaille depuis quelques
années avec le département des Yvelines
et récemment avec la ville de trappes et
c'était une bonne opportunité pour nous
de venir présenter le travail qu'on fait
depuis de nombreuses années avec le
département et la ville de Trappes sur
l'accessibilité et l'inclusion des
personnes en situation de fragilité deux
grandes façons de trouver des solutions
la première c'est soit on est essayons
de prendre le problème d'une autre façon
de d'aller faire des approfondissements
des nouvelles façons de de récolter des
données de cerner mieux le problème et
après c'est de concevoir des solutions
ça c'est la première grande façon et
l'autre façon c'est vraiment en
co-construisant la solution avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes il
faudrait essayer de trouver les
solutions tous ensemble avec nos angles
les mettre ensemble nos angles
d'analyses les mettre ensemble et
essayer vraiment à partir de là de se
mettre en synergie pour fabriquer une
solution un peu plus globale pour
l'enfant et non pas juste découper les
différentes séquences de vie de l'enfant
et donc ces experts ont pu animer ces
trois tables rondes Catherine Arnaud
alors on détailler un tout petit peu ce
qui s'est passé lors de cette journée du
21 septembre il a été question notamment
de la ville inclusive vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure de quoi s'agit-il
justement alors la ville inclusive c'est
comment dans des dans des quartiers qui
sont des quartiers d'habitat collectif
extrêmement dense comment on peut
repenser la ville pour que tout le monde
y trouve sa place qu'on soit en
situation d'emplois ou en situation de
chômage quand c'est en situation de
handicap qu'on soit en situation de
difficultés scolaires comment tout le
monde peut trouver sa place dans cette
nouvelle lecture de la de la ville et
puis c'est aussi la vue l'inclusive
c'est aussi penser la ville qui ne
souffre pas des dérèglements climatiques
c'est à dire comment accompagner ces
territoires à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique c'est vous savez
que c'est une vraie une vraie
problématique les appartements des
logements sociaux construits il y a 40
ans sont très chauds en été très froid
en hiver on a besoin d'accompagner et
puis la ville elle-même a besoin de
saisie l'autre fraîcheur alors que ce
sont des villes très minérales et donc
comment on peut repenser la ville pour
tous il y a aussi une solution qui a été
évoquée au cours de la deuxième table
ronde c'est ce qu'on appelle l'urbanisme
temporaire qu'est-ce que c'est
l'urbanisme temporaire alors l'urbanisme
temporaire c'est comment positiver d'une
difficulté la difficulté c'est ces
programmes de renouvellement urbain sont
des programmes sont extrêmement longs
extrêmement long et qui doivent mettre
autour de la table beaucoup
d'intervenants qui doivent faire
participer complètement les habitants
l'évolution des quartiers et ce sont des
programmes très longs pendant ce temps
long qui n'est pas toujours le temps de
l'habitant il y a des lieux qui en fait
perdre leur première vocation parce
qu'ils ont été par exemple vider de leur
premier vocation parce qu'ils ont ils
vont être ils vont être démoli et puis
et puis il y a des lieux qui vont qui
vont se transformer et avant leur état
ultime avant le moment où ils auront
effectivement la vocation qu'on leur a
donné au long terme on n'imagine pas que
ce puisse être détend mort avec des
lieux vides et comment penser ce temps
intermédiaire à la fois pour créer des
actions pour créer des d'autres
idées actions qui vont en fait nourrir
le programme à venir aussi donc voilà
c'est le temps intermédiaire qui est un
temps qui est trop long pour les
habitants et dans laquelle on a décidé
de donner du corps et la dernière table
ronde c'était donc transformée ces
quartiers aussi en transformant l'offre
éducative ici sur Chanteloup-les-Vignes
vous avez précurseur puisque il y a ce
nouveau dispositif les cités éducatives
une des premières dans les Yvelines si
ce n'est même la première a été lancée
du côté de Chanteloup-les-Vignes c'est
la cité éducative Simone Veil
l'éducation c'est vous l'avez dit aussi
tout à l'heure une une part importante
une partie importante pour aussi œuvrer
la transformation de ces quartiers
l'éducation c'est d'abord la certitude
d'accompagner nos enfants pour devenir
des hommes et des femmes qui prennent
place dans la société l'éducation c'est
aussi remettre le parent au cœur de ce
dispositif qui n'est plus seulement le
dispositif de l'enseignement l'éducation
c'est aussi ce que regarde un parent qui
arrive sur un territoire comment mon
enfant va pouvoir être entouré
accompagné et donc le lieu le bâti les
projets qui sont autour de l'éducatif
sont le centre de l'évolution de nos
collectivités locales et un peu plus
dans ces quartiers
dernière question on l'imagine viendra
après un bilan de cette journée
d'échange autour de la question des
quartiers politiques de la ville est-ce
que ça pourra nourrir peut-être un futur
travail départemental qui est déjà
enclenché mais est-ce que ça pourra
servir nourrir votre réflexion alors
bien sûr mais pas seulement la l'idée et
la pensée du conseil départemental
l'idée c'est aussi que les partenaires
eux-mêmes se nourrissent de ces travaux
en commun à la fois des des projets que
portent le département de l'ambition
qu'il y met mais on sait très bien que
l'ambition elle doit se décliner au
niveau local et elle doit se décliner
par les élus par les habitants par les
partenaires par les éducateurs enfin par
tout le monde et je pense que il y aura
d'autres métamorphoses
urbaines merci Catherine Arnaud mère de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes vice-présidente du
conseil départemental en charge de
l'insertion et de la rénovation urbaine
c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de nous avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]